[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando los parapolíticos como alguna
autoridad
siempre tratando de colocar unas en
otras oportunidades
[Música]
en el sector que nos refleja nuestras
amistades a estas palabras
y no al manifestar
como en la impresión
también puede activar
visita
[Música]
en 15% tuviera un sobre
tuvieron una evaluación sobresaliente
en ciencia matemática y conversión
lector
cualquier anuncio
[Música]
por ciento más
si realmente
pero
[Risas]
[Música]
desde 30 25 30 y para eso tenemos un
acuerdo nacional viaje político
como profesor en los alumnos
cientos de árboles
[Música]
es precisamente en este entonces donde
el grande
eso sí contienen el guardián él
y
[Música]
y sus hijos
sale nunca efectivamente con una
cuestión de realidad
y después las minas
[Música]
qué más
colocamos en la cabeza bueno si no es
súper médico
en el momento porque
[Música]
a las 1030 nacional como lo hablamos
para mejorar esa es la diferencia
también
pero
[Música]
de la marina
sí
y tú
pero una dieta
con la técnica en las redes sociales del
autismo
por una oración por él
dolor
[Música]
en tanto la educación del niño disfruta
[Aplausos]
donde tendrá mucha gente contenta
el mundo
domínguez
2 me presiona
[Música]
y
una máquina de dos mil pesos
de 12 meses a 166
y como es
[Música]
mensuales
bien bueno puede quedar enterrada debajo
y
y tal
[Música]
de personas y luego mantienen una
relación profunda de marc habilidades
se escribirá necesita que la persona
una pregunta tenemos diseños y me sentí
short análisis
también encajan antes de continuar con
nosotros la pega también que escucha
pobres entrar josé
o sea que la granadina
desde el taxi de servicio tan importante
en cuanto a josé s
y bueno vamos bien qué tiempo durante
contenta del df pasó más tiempo no tiene
hijos
un poco de dinero para una duración
y tú muy difícil ya trabajando en el
valle
[Música]
ah
en una misma quiero creo que hay un
lugar en algunos temas
en las fotos que sienten que necesitamos
digan
en un bar
pero nosotros
[Música]
tuve la oportunidad de trabajar para el
mismísimo ventas
en el presente con creativos de poder
utilizar a una persona excelente
llegando
llegando a las bestias que dicen que el
primero la primera foto de la técnica
[Música]
i
la gente siente la música
[Música]
únicamente han dejado que la
contaminación
me concentro
cuando nos ven a nosotros nos encanta
esta semana 30 especial
y
con un clic en dos versiones de tintín
es un anhelo social de ayudar a la
educación
tiene 70 música
en la cocina de la villa
y todo para nada
y nos llega mejor claro
supongo que todo ello está respaldado
computacional
la persona
y él
es decir nada
para montoro
quería jugar a término
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de dos o tres años hacia atrás
y todos esos años
y lo logramos
porque el robo
[Música]
para mí
cuando empezaron a analizar bien la
situación
[Música]
de las otras 45 gente que teníamos
no sé por qué
igualmente
gracias mismo el problema social
y ellos decían
no sé
entonces la universidad municipal
y así es
a las formas
[Música]
y
un día en todo sentido utilización
un día determinado y
y esta dosis
en el signo
no es posible
[Música]
si se puede hacer
gracias
porque no entiendo
pero en el cual muchos 15
y aumentado de 26 años muy buena persona
contra profesional
y esa es la cara del presidente
municipal de su partido
pero digo
y porque la gente joven canadiense 6% la
foto
terminó siendo el cocinado por años el
siguiente
[Música]
a los éxitos
una buena canción
[Música]
por qué
pl
es impresionante
y por países latinoamericanos
pero no puede
[Aplausos]